ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
STARTING AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN I
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TO AN
EDUCATION FINANCE THIS IS OUR
SECOND HEARING ITS DAYS ARE
OVER THE HEARING ON THE K.
TWELVE AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PIECE. OF THAT.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
AND- WE ARE BEGINNING OF COURSE
OUR DELIBERATIONS FOR THE YEAR
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
ABOUT FIFTY HOURS OF PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND TESTIMONY FROM.
MANY OF YOU OUT HERE SO THIS IS
JUST THE BEGINNING AND TODAY OF
COURSE IS THE OVERVIEW HEARING
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO HEAR FROM
OUR- STATE FOR TEN A PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION TALKING ABOUT THE-
OFFICE CALLED THE VERY. RULES
AND WILL LAUNCH INTO
DELIBERATIONS START THE
LIBERATION PROCESS OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY. BUDGET ACCOLADE
TO K. TWELVE AN EARLY AT AND-
WILL FOCUS TODAY ON THE BIG
PICTURE. I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE TALK ABOUT THE OVERALL
SCHOOLHELPED OF OURS WELL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. LEARN FOR LEARNING
THIS DOES OR SOME. IN THE
BUDGET WILL ABOUT THE- VIEW
TODAY TURNED AGAINST THAT THAT
INVOLVED IN THE COMING WEEKS.
AND THERE ARE SOME. INTEREST
HOLES IN HERE WAY TO OUR
SCHOOLS FROM THE GOVERNOR WE
WENT TO BALANCE THOSE AND HOW
THEY WILL ADDRESS. THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS- LOOK AT
ADDRESSING OUR ACHIEVEMENT GAP
WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
BALANCE WHAT ARE DISTRICTS
NEED. TO STAY AFLOAT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SO WITH THAT SAID
LET'S BEGIN OUR HEARING TODAY
AND ASK- TWENTY THIRTY MINUTES
CERTAINLY AFRAID OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. AND OUR S. DIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA. TO SHARE A FEW
WORDS WITH US THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON TONY THURMOND STATE.
ATTENDED A PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND STAFF ABOUT IT WHEN YOU
SAID FIFTY HOURS OF HEARINGS I
NEARLY PASSED OUT. AS I HAD A
FLASH BACK TO- PREVIOUS
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT WE CHAIRED
BUT- THE WORK IS IMPORTANT WE
THANK YOU FOR IT. I WOULD LIKE
TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
NEWEST ADDITION- AND STAFF TO
THIS COMMITTEE- WE'RE PLEASED
TO. WORK CLOSELY WITH YOUR
TEETH. AND ON ANY ISSUES.
REGARDING WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OUR STATE. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
NUMBER STAFF FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ARE A CHIEF DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT STEPHANIE GREX
INTIMATELY TO MY RIGHT-
CONTINUING TOMORROW RIGHT TO MY
RIGHT- JULIE INQUIRE ABOUT WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS. AND TO MY FAR RIGHT
GAME TANK TURNO WHO WORKS IN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS ON A NUMBER
OF OUR BUDGET RELATED ITEMS. I
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE.
OVERALL I LIKE TO SAY- WE ARE
PLEASED WITH THE STATE BUDGET
AND HW IT IN AGENTS EDUCATION.
HOW WE THINK THAT IT DOES BRING
BOARD MEDI CREATIVE. PROPOSALS
IT'S VERY THOUGHTFUL- IN BROAD
IT THINKS ABOUT THINGS LIKE
TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION WHICH WE KNOW IS A
CRITICAL NEED. ANY GIFT SO FAR.
TOO MANY OF PRETTY. TO ADDRESS
THESE OF MAY OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE IMPACTED. I OUR OUR- GAP IN
THE WORK THAT. THERE THAT IS
WITHOUT HEY. AND WITH A BUDGET
HAS ONE BULLET DESERVES A- HAS
NEED IN THE REVENUE THAT WE
HAVE. WHILE IMPORTANT US IS A
ALWAYS ENOUGH IN A WAY ARE
STATE BY WORKS IN OUR OVERALL
STATE SYSTEM OF. WERE WE KNOW
THAT THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE WE CANNOT IGNORE THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA IS. THE FIFTH
WEALTHIEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
BUT THE REVENUES AT OUR STATE
CAN GENERATE ONLY ALLOW US TO
BE THIRTY NINTH AND IT SHOULD
THE PER PUPIL SPENT. THAT'S MY
WAY OF SAYING WE OUGHT TO WORK
TODAY. ABOUT THAT- OUTSIDE OF
THIS INSTITUTION THAT WE WILL
BE A PART OF IN SUPPORT- BUT IN
THE MEANTIME WE FOCUS ON WHAT.
IS IN THIS CURRENT BUDGET. ALL
IT PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS- TO
SUPPORT- COSTS FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WE KNOW THAT THEY
NEED MORE. AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN CREATIVELY. FUND SPENDING
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS A PERHAPS
THE BIGGEST ALLOCATION AND THAT
IS NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT. TEACHER RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION- WE KNOW THAT YOU
CANNOT CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP WITHOUT A WILL. PREPARE
SUPPORTED TEACHER AT THE HEAD
OF EVERY CLASS WE HAVE A
TEACHER SHORTAGE IN THE STATE
JUST LIKE MANY STATE OUR
NATION. OUR BUDGET IS VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW IT GOES
ABOUT- GOING OUT WILL BE IS TO
ADDRESS. WE CLOSE THAT
SHORTAGE. THE BUDGET. ALSO IS
VERY CREATIVE IN THINKING ABOUT
THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS WHO
ARE HOMELESS. AND POVERTY. HAVE
BEEN EXPECTED FROM. ANOTHER TO
AT MY CHAO. THAT CREATE
BARRIERS TO SUCCESS WE KNOW
THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN OVERCOME
THESE BARRIERS BUT ANY REASON.
TO DO THAT LIKE THIS THE
COUNSELORS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
FOR THOSE REASONS A BAD- WITH
GOVERNOR ON THE NOTION OF
EXPANDING COMMITTED. TO THIS
CALIFORNIA. IN SPITE. SO THAT
THE TWO. SOME THREE. IN THE- OF
THIS. POST A WAIT SUPPORT DISH
THAT HAVE HIGH OF POVERTY IN
RATES RACIAL. AND A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF TEACHERS WHO NOT
GOOD AT AND TO SUPPORT THOSE
DISTRICTS OF THIS BUDGET
ENVISIONS A NEW GRANT PROGRAM-
OPPORTUNITY GRANTS PROGRAM-
THAT WOULD SUPPORT. THOSE
STUDENTS AND THIS THROUGH THIS
BUDGET RECOGNIZES THAT
LITERALLY WE HAVE MANY HUNGRY
STUDENTS AND IS THE FIRST
BUDGET AND DECADES THAT
ALLOCATES MONEY FOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS. THE TUNE OF SIXTY.
MILLION DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ANOTHER TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO
PROVIDE TRAINING ON WAYS TO
PROVIDE. HEALTHY MEALS AND
SUPPORT THEM IN BEING CREATIVE
AND HOW THEY WILL PROVIDE THOSE
MEALS WE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THIS
BUDGETS FOCUS ON PRESCHOOL AND
EARLY EDUCATION. AND ITS
APPLICATION TO HAVE SOME TEN
THOUSAND NEW STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS. AND THAT THIS BUDGET
GIVE CONSENT TO HOW WE PREPARE
OUR STUDENTS FOR THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW. IN THE THAT SPACE.
ALEX SOME. IN DOLLARS THIS
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND HOW WE CAN
BUT- TEN THOUSAND EDUCATORS WHO
WORK IN AREAS RELATED TO.
RECIPIENTS AND STEAM IS IT JUST
A FEW OF THE- HIGHLIGHTS
OVERVIEW A COUPLES OF THING.
YOU KNOW WE CALL OUT IN THE
BUT- I KNOW THAT THERE'S ALSO.
SIXTY SIX GOOD FOR BE IN. IN
THE BUT- TO. SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND JEEZ BOTH. TIME. FOR MORE
BEER ARTIST SPECIAL CASE. THESE
IT. WE SUBMIT TO YOU AT SOME OF
THE HIGHER OVER. WHAT'S IN THE
BUDGET BUT WE LIKE TO ALSO. A
TAKE QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE FOR US ABOUT THE BUDGET IN
OUR WORK- TO SUPPORT SIX
MILLION STUDENTS IN OUR STATE.
QUESTIONS FOR A SUPERINTENDENT
MISTER MEDINA WELL FIRST
WELCOME TO THE SUPERINTENDENT-
IF I WROTE WROTE IT DOWN
CORRECTLY YOU YOU MENTIONED
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION YES SIR I BELIEVE THE
LAST YEAR YOU SPOKE ABOUT A
PRIORITY FOR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS-
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT
IF TEACHERS REFLECT THE
STUDENTS THEY TEACH STUDENTS
WILL DO BETTER. AND SO I JUST
WANT TO ASK THE QUESTION WHAT
WHAT ARE YOU IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION DOING. TO
SPECIFICALLY RECRUIT TEACHERS
OF COLOR. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA- AND- I'M GONNA ASK OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE SPECIFIC PROGRAM SOME
SCHOLARSHIPS AND SOME OTHER
THINGS HOW NINE HUNDRED MILLION
BREAKS OUT- BUT WHAT I'D SAY TO
YOU IS THAT WE AGREE. THAT WE
HAVE. FIGHT MAKE SURE WORKFORCE
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STUDENTS AND IN THAT RESPECT-
IS EXPLORING HOW EXPENSE OF OUR
MILLAGE CATER OF COLOR PROGRAMS.
HOW THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN
THE NIGHT DID MILLION OTHER BUT
IT CAN BE CUSTOMIZE AND
TAILORED TO HELP. FROM CRUDE
AND RETAIN A DIVERSE WORKFORCE-
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING OTHERS ABOUT ANY
THAT IS A BARRIER. TO
CANDIDATES OF COLOR WHO CHOOSE
TO ENTER THE FORCE THERE ALWAYS
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WELL WHAT
ARE THE REQUIREMENTS TO BECOME
A TEACHER AND HAD A WEEK AMEND
POST MAKE SURE YOU PUT. THE
BEST STRATEGIES- THEIR
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE HANDLE
RECIPROCITY MEETING SOMEONE
THAT- CREDENTIAL FROM AN
UPSTATE AND HOW DO WE GET
EASIER ONE. WHO WANT TO TEACH
IN CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO
TEACH A- PLAN SO WE ARE
ENGAGED. IN THE STATE IS. YEAH
BUT WE DO. WHEN NOW WE-
CONSIDER. THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS READ CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT AND BY TRYING AND HOW WE
SHOULD EDUCATORS THERE BECAUSE
WE THINK BIAS EXISTS IN EVERY
SINGLE SECTOR AND WE HAVE TO DO
ALL THAT WE CAN OFFSET THOSE BY
PEACE AND THAT WE WANT TO-
TRULY- HAVE WORK THAT WILL
REFLECT. THE CITY OF OUR
STUDENTS IT IS AFTER A DEEP YOU
SEE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. IT
PROGRAMS FALL DOWN FOR TEACHER
ME TO. RATES DITION TO WHAT OUR
SUPERINTENDENT TALKED ABOUT
WERE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN.
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION ON
HUMAN RESOURCES PRACTICES SO
GUIDANCE FOR OUR DISTRICTS
AROUND THE HUMAN RESOURCES
PRACTICES TO HAVE A VERY
INCLUSIVE HIRING PROCESS AND
STRATEGIES. SO THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO BREAK HIS DOWN
AROUND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS EDUCATED
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT GRANT
THERE WAS INITIALLY STARTED
LAST YEAR. INCREASING THAT AND-
IT SO THAT YOU CAN. BY
PROFESSION. TO OUR CLASSIFIED
STAFF AND OUR ADMINISTRATORS
AND OUR TEACHERS AS WELL
THERE'S A NINE. BILLION DOLLARS
GRANTS FOR WORK FOR
DEVELOPMENT. AND FOR IN HIGH IN
STRATEGIES AND HUNDRED SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS
AND TO OF TEACHER READ. GRAHAM
HUNDRED MILLION FOR A- BUT
ENSURE WARD RAM. AND SIX POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE-
USERS PROTECT PROGRAM. EIGHT
MILLION FOR THE- FOR IT IS
STILL ON A PUBLIC RELATIONS. I
WOULD I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
CHAIR THIS CAN AUTHORED TO HELP
CLASSIFIED STAFF BECOME
EDUCATORS THAT IS ONE OF THE
MORE WILDLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN OUR STATE
FOR HELPING US TO CLOSE.
TEACHER SHORTAGE AND TRACKED
MORE DIVERSE EDUCATORS I WOULD
ALSO JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE
REALLY DID THAT WHEN GOVERNOR.
LAID OUT HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IN
JANUARY HE SPOKE DIRECTLY TO
THE NEED TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP HE SPOKE
DIRECTLY TO THE NEEDS TO-
CREATING RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION. DESIGNS THAT WILL
HELP US TO DIVERT ATTRACT A
MORE DIVERSE WORK FORCE AND
CLOSE THE GAP. AND SO MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE IN THE
BUDGET ARE CALLED OUT BUT WE'RE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE SUPPORT
SPECIFICS IN PLACE. THAT WILL
HELP US RESULT IN A MORE
DIVERSE TEACHER SO IT IN NUMBER.
ARE ARE WE MAKING PROGRESS.
THIS STATE GOVERNING MEGAN
TOWARDS THAT END YOU KNOW IT
WAS NUMBERS GETTING BETTER JUST
A WEEK AGO WE CONVENE A- A
SERIES OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
EDUCATIONAL EXPERTS ON WHERE WE
ARE AS RELATED TO TEACH
DIVERSITY. THE HEAD OF THE
COMMISSION ON SHE COULD
ACTUALLY. DID LAY OUT HOW THERE
HAS BEEN AN INCREASE. IN SOME
CATEGORY FOR TEACHERS OF COLOR
BUT IT UP THAT. WILL HAVE A- OF
SPECIFIC DATA SHOW THAT THERE'S
A LINK. IN THE NUMBER OF
TEACHERS WHO IDENTIFIES LATINO-
BUT THAT WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO THERE AND AS IT
RELATES TO- AG TEACHERS. WHO
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MISTER MURATSUCHI
THANK YOU THIS IS
SUPERINTENDENT ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE YOU WELCOME BACK THANK YOU
SIR. YOU KNOW- I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU I WAS GOING TO.
SAVE THIS FOR WHEN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CAME BUT I WE MIGHT
NOT HAVE OUR- WE HAVE YEAH WHY
NOT NOW. SO I I'M LOOKING AT A-
A RECENT LETTER FROM THE
EDUCATION COALITION- AS YOU
KNOW ITS- MADE UP OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF CTA. R. P. T. A.
C. C. A. CSPA IN OUR
ADMINISTRATORS. CFT CASPA AN
AXE. ARM AND THE MESSAGE THAT I
HEARD MY MEETING WITH THEM IS
THAT. YOU KNOW ENDS IN SO MANY
WORDS THAT BEFORE WE START
TALKING ABOUT- CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS THAT WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT
ARE WE'RE NOT ADEQUATELY
FUNDING OUR EXISTING- SCHOOLS
NO AND ESPECIALLY IN A TIME
WHEN. AND ARE OUR BIGGEST URBAN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LAUSD
SACRAMENTO OAKLAND YOU KNOW
THEY THAT THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT. POTENTIALLY GOING UNDER
UNDER THE- THE AREA. THE
OBLIGATIONS AND SO- YEAH I KNOW
THAT THEIR NUMBER ONE REQUEST
IS TO. FOR US TO AN INCREASE
THE LCF TARGETS TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. BEFORE WE START
TALKING ABOUT- FUNDING- YOU
KNOW THE THESE NEW PROGRAMS
LIKE I WANT TO GET YOUR SENSE
ON NOW IF YOU KNOW WHETHER WE
ARE MEETING THE CORE NEEDS OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS. OKAY YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
JUST SAY THAT I HE- STATED IT
YEAH OPENING REMARKS FOR US TO
BE AND THE NATION OF PER PUPIL
SPENDING. IS A PATH CANNOT
ARGUE. CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
NEEDS MORE REVENUE I THINK JUST
ABOUT EVERY EXPERT WHO'S EVER
WRITTEN ON THE SUBJECT. SAID.
CALIFORNIA-DRIVERS-PAY-UNDERFUNDED-STATE-PATROL-PENSION.
US THE REALITY THAT WE ALSO
HAVE A STRUCTURE CHALLENGE.
STATE DOESN'T GENERATE ENOUGH
REVENUE TO COVER ALL THE NEEDS
OF OUR IT SHOULD ONLY. A LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET IF LOOK THERE.
SPENT FOR KATE APPROVE A TWELVE
EIGHT AN OUTRAGE CATION IS
PROBABLY FIFTY PERCENT. OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET. OTHER IN SO I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT IT IS
TRUE THAT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
NEED MORE REVENUE NOW AND THEY
ARE STRUGGLING I SUBMIT TO YOU
THAT THIS IS NOT AN EXCLUSIVE
PROPOSITION TO SAY THAT YOU
ONLY FOR. THEIR BOTTOM LINE AND
IT NOR BUT ALSO NEED YOU BETTER
WE HAVE TO DO MORE. IN A WAY
THAT'S FOCUS ON HOW WE CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP WITH THE
LITTLE THINGS BUT TENNIS. EIGHT
TRIED TO WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ASIAN THE FIFTH. WEEK SUPPORT
THE COMMERCE ABOUT EXPANDING
REVENUE WE NEED MORE PERMANENT
REVENUE SOURCES WE'VE GOT TO
WORK TOWARDS THAT- AND IT THAT
WAY. AND ABOUT A DOZEN WORK
GROUPS THAT TO FOCUS ON ALL THE
ISSUES THAT WE THINK ARE
DISTRICTS OUR FOCUS ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION- CLOSING THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE OF CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND THE ISSUE
OF REVENUE HOW WE CREATE
PERMITS. IS A SCHOOL THIS WE
HAVE PARTICIPATION FROM A
THOUSAND FOLKS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE MOSTLY EDUCATORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS FROM A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND THAT GROUP
CONTINUES AND WE'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
ANY OTHER- YOU NOBODY AND IN
THIS INSTITUTION TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CREATE. HERMIT SOURCES
OF REVENUE BECAUSE WAS MUCH AS
ITS BUDGET DOES IN PREVIOUS
BUDGETS HAVE DONE. WE KNOW THAT
WHEN THERE'S A DOWNTURN- THAT
MEANS WE'RE GOING TO BE OUT AND
ARE DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO FEEL
IT LIKE YOU KNOW WE COME FROM.
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED I SERVED ON A SCHOOL
BOARD THAT. YOU KNOW LITERALLY
WAS AT CLOSE TEN SCHOOLS HIGH
FOR ME SCHOOLS THAT SERVE. THEM
KIDS IT WAS ALL BECAUSE IT
WASN'T THE OUT. ARE OUR OUR
WORST. AND BUT- THINK OF WEEK
WEEK WE CAN JUST WE HAVE TWO
MORE WITH WHAT WE HAVE WE HAVE
TO CREATE PERMANENT SOURCES IN
AND SO OUR WORK GROUP ON
EXPANDING REVENUE IS FOCUS ON
THAT AND WOULD LOVE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH YOU AND OTHERS WHO
ARE INTERESTED ALL RIGHT I
CERTAINLY AND- IN FULL SUPPORT.
OF A- EXPLORING IN AT ALL-
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
EDUCATION REVENUES A I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY CONCERNS
ABOUT YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY IF
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT- THE
INEVITABLE DOWNTURN SOMETIME IN
THE NEAR FUTURE- WHETHER WE
SHOULD BE EXPANDING PROGRAMS
NOW RATHER THAN- FOCUSING ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS MR DONALD RIGHT
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY IN YOUR
THOUGHTS AND I JUST HOPE YOU'LL
BECOME A CHAMPION WITH US I
MEAN AND I JUST. FIGURE BACK ON
MISTER MOORE SEARCHES COMMENTS
THE CALL IS WAY TOO LOW TWO
POINT 29% I THINK THAT'S A NO
BRAINER- SURE THAT DOESN'T EVEN
BEAT CPI. RIGHT SO THAT'S A
REAL PROBLEM- AND WE WERE EVEN
DRAWING DOWN RESERVES IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S PROPOSED BUDGET WHICH
IS A PROBLEM- AND SOMETHING
THAT I'VE BEEN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. IDENTITY WAS
CREATED- BEFORE I GOT HERE
PROBABLY ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO
THE CC EITHER CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE I BELIEVE THEY DON'T
REPORT TO YOU IS THAT ACCURATE.
THEY DO NOT IN WELL I THINK
THEY SHOULD NAY BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO SEE A LITTLEBIT MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING ON THE FIELD
A- IN IT YOU KNOW WHAT THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE OUR ONE STOP
SHOP FOR EXPERTISE. IT'S KIND
OF FLOATING OUT THERE I'M AWARE
THEY BELONG- IS SO I THAT'S A
THAT'S A CONVERSATION I'D LIKE
TO HAVE GO FORWARD. I WITH THIS
TURN BACK. OF ONE OF THE- YEAH
THINK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR IS A MEMBER O'DONNELL AYE
WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE OB WOULD
LIKE SEE THE TO BE EITHER WE
ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE THIS
BUDGET I THINK ENVISIONS THE
BEST USE OF WHAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY BOTH IN ONE TIME
DOLLARS AND SOME ONGOING
DOLLARS- YOU KNOW YOU AND I
KNOW BOTH WELL THAT BY THE END
OF THIS BUDGET SESSION. THAT
BUDGET MAY LOOK VERY DIFFERENT
YEAH AND YOU KNOW IT I KNOW
THAT THE PROJECTIONS OF REVENUE
HAS CHANGED FROM THE TIME THAT
THIS BUDGET WAS SUBMITTED TO
NOW- AND- SHOULD THAT CONTINUE
TO BE FAVORABLE OF YOU KNOW-
THAT ANYTHING'S. LATER WILL BE.
BAD AS THE C. C. E. UM YEAH I
WAS A LOT OF PEOPLE ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW ALL OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
FIT INTO THE MIX ABOUT WHAT WE
DO WE WORK WITH ALL OF THEM-
BUT WE THINK IT EVERY
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE TO EXAMINE
HOW WE ADMINISTER EDUCATION IN
THE STATE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO THAT IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY WE WANT AT THE SITE
PARTNERSHIP WITH C. C. E. R.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION OR
OR ANYONE ELSE HAS BEEN ALL. I
TO WORK WITH KIDS OF CALIFORNIA
PART OF EDUCATION. SERIOUSLY TO
DO A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE TO
ASSIST AND SUPPORT ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT NEEDS IT- THE
WE'VE CREATED SOME STRUCTURES
TO ALLOW US. TO BETTER DO THAT-
TO FOCUS ON HOW WE CAN INCREASE
REVENUE. IN THE STATE SORRY WE
BRING THE CHECKBOOK HERE TODAY
WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL. THE
STATE CHECKBOOK BUT WE AGREE.
THEY SHOULD NEED MORE REVENUE
AND TO ALWAYS BE DRIVING CHANGE
TO HELP CALLED THE TREATMENT
GAP SOLVE OUR STUDENTS COULD
GREAT QUALITY EDUCATION. GREAT
THANK YOU AND I ARE GOVERNMENTS
OF. OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEMS FOR DESPAIR RIGHT TO A
LEVELS A LOT GOING ON OUT
THERE- THERE IF THEY'RE QUITE A
FEW LEVELS RIGHT. AND I DO THAT
WHEN I LOOK AT THIS YOU SEE
THAT WHOSE UMBRELLAS AND UNDER.
THAT GETS A LITTLE CONFUSING TO
ME AND THAT'S JUST ONE OTHER
ELEMENT. ANTIQUATED BRING OF.
UNDER ONE UMBRELLA EVEN
CREATING WAS THE DEPARTMENT OF.
EDUCATION. BUT THEN AGAIN I
GUESS SOME THE DUTIES WILL
STILL BE IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE CREATING AN
APARTMENT. REALLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. SO THOSE ARE
CONVERSATIONS WILL HAVE GOING
FORWARD I THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AT WHICH IS SAID TO YOUR LAST
POINT ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION I
THINK THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF.
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THAT WILL
LOOK ONE THING THAT IS CLEAR IS
THAT IF IT HAS THE ABILITY TO.
STREAMLINE A SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED THE FAMILIES- ALONE
THE CONTINUUM. OF SUPPORT IN
CHILDCARE AND- HOME VISITING-
WE CAN SUPPORT IT YEAH I SEE.
SOMETHING THAT. DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT'S NOT
BEEN DONE BEFORE IN THE STATE.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING. THE HOUSE
KING IN OTHER STATES. AND OTHER
IMPACTS. AND BENEFITS FOR OUR
KIDS AND FAMILIES- WILL. BE
SUPPORTED WITH A FOUR FOUR IS
THAT. THE FORMATION OF THAT
DEPARTMENT IS BEING GUIDED. BY
THE STATE'S- EARLY EDUCATION
MASTER PLAN. AND THAT THAT WILL
REALLY POINT TO. A WHAT IS THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
WAY. TO SUPPORT OUR OUR YOUNG
ARE YOUNGEST CHILDREN. AND
THEIR- CONSERVE TUNE ON THAT
COMMON STATE. CERTAINLY WELCOME.
INPUT BACK THE STATE AND- MY
SERVICES A GOOD THING. BUT CREE
BUREAUCRACY MORE WE ARE. MAIN
SO THAT'S JUST OF LIKE WE'RE
THINKING THROUGH THAT LENS WELL
THANK YOU IF I NEVER SEE
ANYTHING ELSE WOULD BE ON THE
RECORD THAT. I WANT TO. OR BE
SICK. USE BUT ESPECIALLY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU I KNOW
WE HAVE A BUT I WANTED PIPING A
LITTLE BIT FOLLOW UP WITH
MURATSUCHI SAID OF COURSE WE
WANT BOTH WE MORE MONEY OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND PROPERLY
FUNDING LCF PFAFF AND THIS CALL
UP AND LOOKING AT THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE KNOW MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND FOR OUR KIDS
THAT ARE THAT ARE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD SO FAR FOR. IN A
LOBBY DAY FOR VENN DIVISIONAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND NOW I HAVE
I'M SURE YOU HAVE AS WELL AND
WE'RE HEARING THE ONE QUESTION
SO FAR IS ASSUMING IT DOESN'T
GET ANY BETTER AND IS NOT ONE
MORE PENNY IN THAT. MAY
REVISION. AND WE HAD JUST THE
MONEY WE HAVE HERE ON THE
TABLE. WOULD WOULD BE WE BETTER
OFF- FLEXING SOME OF THESE
DOLLARS AND YOU LLOWING THEM
TO BE UTILIZED FOR. DISTRICTS
TO DISASTER CORPS NEEDS THE
YEAH WE SAW. YOU KNOW YOU
WORKED HARD TRYING TO FOCUS ON
OUR DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WHICH IS- FINANCIALLY SHAKY.
JUST READ RECENTLY THAT OF THE
SAN DIEGO SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALL
OF ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE IN
THAT CERTIFICATION LEVEL WHICH
ARE. ARE FINANCIALLY TROUBLING
AND SO THAT BEING SAID. YOU
KNOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT
HAVING ALL OF OUR RESOURCES GO
TO KEEP DISTRICTS FINANCIALLY.
STABLE OR DO A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT AND TO FOCUS ON OUR- OUR
CORTINES BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE
TRY TO BE EVERYTHING TO
EVERYBODY. YOU'RE NOTHING TO
NOBODY SO. WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT MR SPI. I'M A
BOTH KIND OF PERSON AS WELL AND
I THINK THAT THE LIKE I SAID
THESE ARE NOT. MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE PROPOSITIONS I THINK
THAT WE DO NEED MORE FUNDING
FOR OUR SCHOOLS OVERALL AND I
THINK THAT WE NEED CREATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS REALLY
CRITICAL NEEDS THAT HAVE BEEN-
LARGELY NOT. ADDRESS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS PRIOR- I THINK THAT
YOU AYE I'VE HEARD FROM- SOME
LEGISLATORS OUTSIDE OF THIS
PARTICULAR CHAMBER WHO ALSO
SAID OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
REALLY HURTING. AND NEED HELP
AND AS IS NO EXTRA MONEY LAYING
AROUND MY SUGGESTION TO THEM.
AND TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS THAT WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
WE LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS TOGETHER
THAT WILL MAKE SENSE FOR OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BOTTOM LINE.
AND WILL MAKE SENSE ON THINGS
THAT REALLY I DON'T THEY ARE.
THE G. I REALLY THAT I GOVERNOR
IS REALLY ALSO WANTING TO DO
MORE AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
FIND WAYS TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR ON IDENTIFYING
SOLUTIONS AND STRATEGIES THAT
WILL MEET ALL OF THE NEEDS OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
ULTIMATELY ARE SIX MILLION
STUDENTS OKAY THANKS FOR CHAIR
YEAH I JUST WANNA YEAH BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THIS BUDGET WE'RE
SLIDING BACK INTO THE CATEGORY
CLARA. AND THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING I THINK WE SHOULDN'T
DO I THINK WE SHOULD SET THE
BAR GIVE DISTRICTS THE
RESOURCES IN THROUGH BUT YOU
KNOW NOT WE'RE ALWAYS DOING WE
SEE A HOLDING SOME OF THEM BACK
SO THEY DON'T. MEAN JUNE
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT SOMETHING
DISCUSS FOR THAT POINT COM. I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE GOVERNOR ON
THE ISSUE OF CAT. IS BUT AS I.
AS I LOOK AT THE BUDGET THAT
HE'S PUT FORWARD I SEE IT
VALUING. WHAT ELSE CFF MEANS TO
OUR DISTRICTS I SEE A 12-1 IF
NOT. I'M GONNA DIE I DON'T
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT
POINT JACK I'M NOT A LOT OF
MONEY SET ASIDE FOR LITTLE
PROJECTS EVERYWHERE YES THAT'S
GREAT. YES BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT DOES SLICE BACK.
TOWARDS THE CATEGORY CLARA HAS
THERE BEEN A CALL FOR
CATEGORICAL SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT I WOULD SAY THIS GOES
RIGHT BUDGET AND I WOULD SAY IT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WERE SLAIN
BACK IN THAT ERA. GOT IT. YEAH
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ARE ALL GOOD IDEAS A
TEACHER. PROGRAMS AND ALL OF
THOSE ARE IDEAS AND THEY'RE
NOT. ESSENTIALLY FLEXIBLE ON
EVERYTHING TO US BY DISTRICTS
WHEN THEY APPLY FOR GRANTS. AS
YOU KNOW MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND KIDS ARE FROM SMALLER
DISTRICTS AND I DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
FOR THOSE OF. MY FOR JUST TWO
OTHER THOUGHTS NOT A QUESTIONS
THE COMMENT IS THAT. YEAH WE'RE
THIRTY NINE. IT'S A DISGRACE
OUR FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS
COMPARISON THERE STATES. I
AGREE WHAT WE YOUR TASK FORCE
AND- MISTER MARTZ SUED SHE AND
I AND SOME OTHER- ASSEMBLY.
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING AT THEIR
CSPA PROPOSALS AND FULL AND
FAIR FUNDING AND TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN BRING THAT BACK
BECAUSE- THESE ARE JUST
BANDAIDS AND SO WE GET THAT.
AND THEN I KNOW WE'LL GET INTO
IT BUT I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU
BEFORE YOU TAKE OFF. ON THE
PROPOSAL ON THE REWARD FOR
EARLY EDUCATION. I HAVEN'T
TAKEN A POSITION ON IT YET
ANOTHER IS ACTUALLY A TRAILER
BILL IN A COMPANION BILL
INTRODUCED AND I THINK THIS
COULD BE NEEDS TO FULLY. THAT
THE IMPLICATIONS IT'S
INTRIGUING. TO HAVE A SOFT KISS
YOU ADD. YOU THINK. MY TAX.
KIDS ARE FAMILY. AND OUR PER.
AND THAT SHOULD BE. OUR ONLY
FOCUS ON HOW IT IMPACTS ADULTS
AND BUREAUCRATS YOU KNOW SO BE
IT SO. I THINK THAT THAT NEEDS
TO BE HOW WE LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
GOING FORWARD SO. I WITH THAT
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ONE
LAST YES- SURE IF I COULD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- ON THE ISSUE
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
HAVE GRANT WRITERS- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
MONITORING WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
SMALLEST. AND RULED TRICKS.
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DONE THERE ARE WAYS TO CREATE.
AN ESTABLISH. FORMULA THAT
ALLOW DISTRICTS TO BE SEE
FUNDS. BASED ON ELIGIBILITY
THAT THEY HAVE WHETHER IT'S
FREE OR REDUCED LUNCH OR OTHER
NEEDS. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE HELP REALLY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. IN MAKING THAT THE
WAY THAT OUR LEGISLATION IN
EDUCATION. THIS IS AN EX. JUST
LAST POINT ON THE SHOW ABOUT
THE SPECIAL PROGRAMS ARE IN THE
BUDGET- YOU KNOW I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT. FOR AS MANY DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN.
ABOUT GETTING RID OF THEM AND
JUST FUNDING DISTRICTS BOTTOM
LINE. I WOULD SAY WE PROBABLY
HEARD FROM AS MANY DISTRICTS TO
SAY. THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEM. AND I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT W- WHAT WE HAVE
TOUGH CHOICES TO MAKE THAT WE
NOT SAY IT'S ONE OF THE OTHER.
BUT THAT WE LOOK FOR WAYS TO
MAXIMIZE WHAT WE HAPPEN TO GET
MORE OF WHAT WE NEED- AND TO
SUPPORT OUR DISTRICTS. AND WE
SAID WE'RE AVAILABLE TO HELP
WITH THAT CONVERSATION AT ANY
POINT AND BE LOVED. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WILL START TO BRING UP NOW ARE-
PANEL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE LA YELLOW. AND
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. BUT
BEFORE THAT WE WILL TAKE THE
ROLE OF THE BEFORE THAT WE WENT
TO INTRODUCE AN ANNOUNCER
WELCOME. OUR NEW EDUCATION
CONSULTANT TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND ERIN CABLE
SIR FIRST DAY ON THE JOB. HER
FIRST HEARING SO- HERE SHE IS
TO HELP US TAKE CARE OF THE
NEEDS OF. CALIFORNIA'S KIDS IN
OUR SCHOOL SO WELCOME. THANK
SURE. THE BATTLE TO THE LOCAL.
CALL THE ROLL THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH. MCCARTY HERE BRO
GALLAGHER I'M ON. MEDINA
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL. OKAY
THANK YOU SO WILL BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THEN LA- AND THEN HEAR FROM OUR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON LEAST
RESIDENTS GET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M SO
I'M JUST GOING TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ARE YOU SHOULD BE
RECEIVING A ONE PAGE HANDOUT-
IN FIGURE ONE OF THAT HAND THAT
IS JUST THE BASIC THE THREE
YEARS OF THE BUDGET WINDOW THE
MINIMUM COUNTY. A FIGURE TO-
GIVES YOU A DETAILED LIST OF
ALL OF THE PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S. THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SPENDING PLAN ON
FOR K. TWELVE ON ONE SIDE AND
ON THE OTHER SIDE YOU'LL SEE
FIGURE THREE IS THE SPENDING
PLAN FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO
WITH THAT I ONCE AGAIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR WAS
DEVELOPED WITH THE ASSUMPTION
OF A VERY EXTRAORDINARILY
STRONG ECONOMY- BOTH AND IF YOU
NOTICE SOME FIGURE ONES BOTH-
PROPOSITIONS NIGHT GENERAL FUND
REVENUES AND PROPERTY TAX ARE
INCREASING OVER THE THREE YEAR
BUDGET WINDOW. THIS IS- IF IT'S
OUT PERFORMING OUR PREVIOUS
EXPECTATIONS- ANOTHER FACTOR
JUST TO NOTE IS THAT WE ARE
STILL SEEN DECLINING ENROLLMENT
SIGNIFICANT DECLINES IN ROMAN
AN AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
THIS A DECLINE AS PRIMARILY DUE
TO A NET NEGATIVE MIGRATION
PEOPLE LEAVING THE STATE. AND
THEN ALSO A CONTINUING DECLINE
IN OUR TRIAL ARE BIRTHRATES- I
THINK IT FINANCE WERE HOPING
THAT NOW WE'RE HAVING A LOT OF
BABIES FOR SOME REASON BUT- SO
PRIMARILY OF. OLD OF THESE
FACTORS- THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
THAT IS GOING TO IS PROJECTED
TO BE IN A TEST ONE OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD WHICH IS
UNUSUAL IN THE HISTORY
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. ON
BUT IS ALSO A RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN THE GUARANTEE FROM
OUR PREVIOUS OB. PROJECTION SO
THREE IN A TWO MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN A
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY I'M AND THEN A
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE EXPECTED- IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHICH IS OVER THE
NINETEEN TWENTY. REVISED
AMOUNTS. ADDITIONALLY IN THIS
PROJECTION YOU'RE GONNA SEE AN
INCREASE IN TO THE DEPOSIT MADE
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT. A LAST
YEAR'S YOU KNOW WE ENDED UP-
MEETING ALL OF THE FACTORS
REQUIRED TO DEPOSIT AND THE
DEPOSIT WAS THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION ERE NOW
ESTIMATING IT WILL NEED TO MAKE
A DEPOSIT OF FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. WHICH IS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MALE FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
WERE ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. STE SHOWING
THAT WE WILL NEED TO NEED TO
TAKE WITH DRAW FROM THE
RESERVE. AND SPEND TOWARDS
EDUCATION AND THIS IS JUST
BECAUSE THE PROP NINETY MINUTE
GUARANTEE IS NOT INSURING
GROWTH- AN ADJUSTMENT UP FOR
THE INFLATION FACTOR. SO
WITHOUT AGAIN I PLAN ON JUST. I
PROVIDED YOU WITH THE DETAILS
BUT I DON'T PLAN ON GOING OVER
THE PROPOSAL'S. SPECIFICALLY IN
FACT THE SUPERINTENDENT DID A
VERY GOOD JOB FOR US AND
PRESENTING OUR PROPOSAL SO I
WON'T NEED. TO REPEAT HIM- BUT
JUST BASICALLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THE GOVERNOR SPENDING PLAN.
YEAH REALLY TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION THE UNCERTAINTY
OF THE WERE FACING IN THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY. AND ALSO JUST
THE NATION THE NATION'S
POLITICS OF THE CLIMATE OF THE
POLITICS SO WHAT WE TRIED TO DO
IN THIS. BUDGET IS BALANCED THE
ONE TIME AND THE GUN ON GOING
EXPENDITURES. FOR THE ONGOING
EXPENDITURES WE FORK FOCUSED ON
THE A LARGEST OF. PROGRAMS
CONTINUE IN THE PROP ANY
GUARANTEE WHICH IS THE ALPHA
FIVE SPECIAL EDUCATION
NUTRITION. SORRY ABOUT THAT SO
SPECIFICALLY OTHER BUDGETING
PROPOSES A ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION OF
CFF THAT IS A TWO POINT TWO
NINE COLA THAT YOU YOU
DISCUSSED EARLIER ALL OTHER
COULD CALL- CATEGORICAL
THRILLER SEE THE SAME COLA AND
THAT TOTALS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ALMOST HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. INCLUDED
IN SHOWN ON THE SHEET IS A SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR- AUGMENTATION TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND THIS IS TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW SPECIAL
EDUCATION REFORM FORMULA. ON
LAST YEAR OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RECEIVE THE SIX HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BUT THEY
RECEIVED AT- INTO OTHER
DIFFERENT PROGRAM SO WE CAN GO
INTO THAT LATER IF YOU WOULD
LIKE MORE INFORMATION.
ADDITIONALLY EITHER SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE THE
NUTRITION REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
THE ONE TIME EXPENDITURES. THEY
ARE REALLY TARGETING RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT IT PROGRAMS AIMED
AT CLOSING THE AT THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AGAIN AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT NOTED THESE ARE-
THESE ONE TIMERS TO ENSURE THAT
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL LEADERS
HAVE THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THE FIRST A GROUP OF
EXPENDITURES AS THE NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
AD FOR TEACHERS- THE DETAILS I
WON'T GO INTO THE DETAILS AGAIN
WE'LL DISCUSS THAT AT ANOTHER
HEARING BUT RESEARCH IS JUST
REALLY INDICATING THAT WILL
PREPARE TEACHER WORK FORCES THE
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN
PREDICTING STUDENTS
ACHIEVEMENT. AND IN CLOSING THE
GAP ACHIEVEMENT GAP HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA HAS STRUGGLED- OVER
MANY YEARS IN RETAINING ITS
TEACHERS AND ALSO PREPARING
THEM. SO ESPECIALLY IN OUR HIGH
NEED A SUBJECT MATTER AREAS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION SCIENCE MATH
SIX THAT ARE A- SO ON THE NEXT
MAJOR EXPENDITURES ON THAT
DETAIL KATE TWELVE LIST. REALLY
WORK WITH THE A NARROWING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO PROPOSALS THAT
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT TARGETED
RESOURCESAND STATE SUPPORT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
INFLUENCE THE STATE'S
PERSISTENCE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS SO
THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TO ESTABLISH
OPPORTUNITY GRANTS ON THE
PROGRAMS WILL TARGET STATE'S
HIGHEST. POVERTY AREAS THOSE
DEEP POVERTY AREAS WITH THE
LOWEST PERFORMING SCHOOLS THESE
ARE INTENSIVE INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS TO ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMIC GAP AND AGAIN THIS IS
NOT A COMPETITIVE GRANT THESE
GRANTS WILL ACTUALLY- BE GIVEN
TO SCHOOLS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
IN NEED OF ASSISTANCE- AND THEN
PROVIDE THEM WITH PLANNED AND
WAYS TO MAKE SYSTEMIC AND
PREVENTS IN THEIR AREAS. ALSO
IT. ALL PUSH THE COMMUNITIES
GRANT. I'M NOT IS JUST REALLY
TO- INCENTIVIZE AS SUPPORTING
THOSE AND INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL MODELS. OF THE LAST-
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS IS
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
AGAIN THIS IS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION THESE ARE ONE TIME
GRANTS IT'LL GO OUT SIMILAR TO
LAST YEAR TO DISTRICTS THAT ARE
PROVIDING PRESCHOOL- THAT HAVE
PRESCHOOL CENTER PROVIDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES TO
THEIR STUDENTS. SO WITHOUT ON
THAT IT IS ALL THAT I WANTED-
TO COVER IN THIS AREA BUT NOW I
WILL. TURN THE MIKE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE SARAH BURTON WHO WILL
COVER THE EARLY LEARNING CARE
PROPOSALS. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
BERNARD THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LIKE LISA SAID I'LL BE
REVIEWING THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY
LEARNING AND CHILD CARE BUDGET
PROPOSALS- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES IT INCLUDES A
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A NEW
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT. IT WILL BE HOUSED
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. IT WILL BE THE
NEW LEAD AGENT FOR CHILDCARE
AND EARLY LEARNING PROGRAM.
OTHER CURRENTLY BEING
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
THERE'S FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
TO ESTABLISH A TRANSITION TEAM
FOR THE NEW DEPARTMENT AS WELL
AS TO ESTABLISH POSITIONS TO
FACILITATE THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING EFFORTS. FOR
CHILDCARE WORKERS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
MULTIPLE AUGMENTATIONS TO
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS INCLUDING A
NET INCREASE OF FIFTY FOUR
MILLION. NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR CAL WORK
STAGE TWO AND STAGE THREE CHILD
CARE. TEN MILLION PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR FUNDS FOR
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED NEW
GENERAL CHILDCARE SLOTS. IN THE
SECOND YEAR ADDITION OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN NONPROFIT
TO NINETY EIGHT. GENERAL FUND
FOR TEN THOUSAND NEW AND NON
ELLIE A FULL DAY STATE
PRESCHOOL FOR. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PROPOSING TO INCREASE THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM. A PROGRAM TO
PROMOTE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES BY SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION AND THAT IS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND- AND
WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY LEESON
OR I OR ONE OF OUR- FINANCE
COLLEAGUES ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. NO QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME ALEJO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN COUPON
WITH THE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL
BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT. AS
YOU KNOW THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE IS DETERMINED
BY ONE OF THREE TESTS IN THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. YOU FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION MENTION THAT
TEST ONE IS THE OPERATIVE TEST
OVER THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE PERIOD.
AND THAT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
IT MEANS THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT STATE REVENUE CHANGES BY
MAY OF THE PROPERTY TO NINETY
GUARANTEE WOULD INCREASE OR
DECREASE ABOUT FORTY CENTS FOR
EACH DOLLAR HIGHER LOOK FOR A
STATE REVENUE. IT ALSO ANY
CHANGES LOCAL PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE WOULD HAVE A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR EFFECT ON THE OVERALL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THIS I TO PAGE WHAT OUR HANDS
BUT THE- IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THREE HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
COMPARED TO THE ESTIMATES FROM
LAST JUNE. THAT'S MAINLY A
STORY ABOUT HIGHER PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY THE GUARANTEE
IS UP FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN MILLION AND THAT'S
MAINLY A STORY ABOUT HIGHER
GENERAL FUND REVENUE TURNING TO
PAGE TWO THE GUARANTEE IN THE
BUDGET YEARS TWO AND A HALF
BILLION ABOVE THE REVISED
NINETEEN TWENTY LEVEL- BRING
THE TOTAL GUARANTEED TO ABOUT
EIGHTY FOUR BILLION. ONE ISSUE
TO EMPHASIZE IN THE BUDGET YEAR
IS THAT THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE AND THIS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE ARE CONNECTED. SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE GUARANTEE
IS HIGHER BY MAY IT'S LIKELY
THE STATE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
LARGER DEPOSITS DEPOSITS TO TE
EXTENT THE GUARANTEE IS LOWER-
THE STATE WOULD PROBABLY BE
ABLE TO. LARGER WITHDRAWALS
FROM THE RESERVE IS THERE THE
SOFT FACTORS THAT COULD AFFECT
THE BUDGET OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS. I TURNING TO PAGE THREE
OF OUR HAND OUT. WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S ESTIMATES OF GENERAL
FUND ROSE REVENUE ARE
REASONABLE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS FAIRLY SIMILAR TO US IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER THAN US IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND A LITTLE BIT BELOW
US IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUT
OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD OUR
ESTIMATES ARE VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL. WE ARE CONTINUING TO
MONITOR SOME RISKS TO THE STATE
ECONOMY INCLUDING SOME
SLOWDOWNS IN TRADE ACTIVITY AND
JOB GROWTH. BUT BASED ON WHAT
WE KNOW TODAY WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S ESTIMATE OF STATE
REVENUE AND THE GUARANTEE SEEM
REASONABLE. THE ADMINISTRATION
IS ABOVE US ON THEIR PROPERTY
TAX ESTIMATES ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD. YOU'LL BE
HEARING MORE FROM US ABOUT THAT
IN THE COMING DAYS BUT I THINK
YOU'LL SEE THAT DIFFERENCE I
KNOW A LITTLE BIT BY THE TIME
WE DO OUR NEXT OUTLOOK IN MAY.
AGAIN ANY CHANGES IN GENERAL
FUND REVENUE OR PROPERTY TAX
ESTIMATES WOULD AFFECT HOW MUCH
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE IN YOUR
OVERALL PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BUDGET. I TURNING TO PAGE
FOUR- ALL OF THE INCREASES IN
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD SUPPORT
NEARLY FOUR BILLION IN NEW
SPENDING FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS YOU THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATED
EARLIER THOSE NEW PROPOSALS ARE
DIVIDED ABOUT EVENLY BETWEEN
ONE TIME AND I'M GOING
AUGMENTATIONS. FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS THE ON GOING FUNDING IS
REALLY A STORY ABOUT THE TWO
POINT 29% COST OF IT JUST
MEANT. MOST OF THE ONE TIME
FUNDING AS YOU HEARD IS ABOUT
IMPROVING THE EDUCATION WORK
FORCE OR IMPROVING ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES FIRST FOR CERTAIN LOW
PERFORMING SCHOOLS. PAGE FIVE
IS JUST A RUNDOWN OF THIS OF
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS IT'S
JUST A DIFFERENT SLICE OF THE
HAD. THE INFORMATION THAT'S ON
THE ADMINISTRATION SHEET I'LL
COVER EACH OF THOSE PROPOSALS
IN MORE DETAIL LATER THIS YEAR
TURNING TO PAGE SIX WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET OVERALL
HAS SOME POSITIVE COMPONENTS-
WE THINK THE MIX OF ONE TIME AN
ONGOING PROPOSAL SEEMS
REASONABLE. HAVING SOME FUNDING
SET ASIDE ONE TIME ACTIVITIES
PROVIDES YOU WITH THE QUESTION
IN CASE THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
DECLINES. IN TAT SCENARIO IT'S
LESS DISRUPTIVE TO ADJUST THE
ONE TIME SPENDING AN ONGOING
PROGRAMS LIKE THE LCF. I THINK
THE BUDGET ALSO WE THINK THE
BUDGET ALSO WITH DRAWS
ATTENTION TO SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES IN EDUCATION- MANY
DISTRICTS FOR EXAMPLE DO
STRUGGLE WITH ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
AND MANY DISTRICTS TO REPORT
HAVEN'T DIFFICULTY FINDING
TEACHERS IN CERTAIN SUBJECT
AREAS TURNING TO PAGE SEVEN WE%
HAVE TWO MAIN CONCERNS TO
DROUGHT YOUR ATTENTION- FIRST
WE THINK THAT SOME OF THE
PROPOSALSARE UNLIKELY TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
CONCERNED ABOUT. THAT WE THINK
MANY OF THE PROPOSALS WOULD NOT
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S
EXISTING EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND- ENHANCE
THE EDUCATION WORKFORCE. MANY
OF THE PROPOSALS ALSO HAVE
LITTLE DETAIL ABOUT HOW THE
FUNDS TO BE SPENT WHICH MAKES
IT DIFFICULT FOR US TO ASSESS
HOW EFFECTIVE THEY MIGHT BE.
SECONDLY WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THE BUDGET DOES NOT PROVIDE
MUCH FISCALLY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I DISTRICTS ARE
FACING COST PRESSURE FROM
VARIOUS SOURCES- PRIMARILY
HIGHER PENSION COSTS AND HIGHER
COSTS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
ARE THE BUDGET DOES PROVIDE A
COLA- BUT GIVEN SOME OF THOSE
OTHER PRESSURES. WE THINK MOST
DISTRICTS HAVE AT. TIGHT
BUDGETS NEXT YEAR. TURNING TO
PAGE EIGHT AND OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE RECOMMEND
YOU CONTINUE TO RELY UPON A MIX
OF ONE TIME AND I'M GOING
SPENDING. DOESN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO BE THE EXACT SAME AS
WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES BUT
WE THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS A
REASONABLE STARTING POINT. I
WOULD RECOMMEND FUNDING A FEW
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ONE TIME
PROPOSALS. FOCUSING
SPECIFICALLY ON THE PROPOSALS
THAT DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS. AND HAVE
CLEAR OBJECTIVES AND SPENDING
REQUIREMENTS. WE RECOMMEND YOU
REJECT MOST OF THE OTHER ONE
TIME INITIATIVES- WHICH WULD
FREE UP ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
FOR OTHER EDUCATION PRIORITIES.
I FINALLY WE RECOMMEND USING
THE BULK OF THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING TO PROVIDE FISCALLY FIT
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE THINK
THAT OF ALL THE OPTIONS ON THE
TABLE. AND HELPING A PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL PAYMENT TO ADDRESS
DISTRICTS UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES- IS THE MOST
PROMISING OPTION. THAT APPROACH
WOULD BOTH IMPROVE THE FISCAL
HEALTH OF THE PENSION SYSTEMS.
AND IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
REDUCE DISTRICT COST ON A LONG
TERM BASIS. IN ADDITION TO
PAYING DOWN LIABILITIES WE
THINK YOU COULD CONSIDER USING
A PORTION OF THAT PENSION
FUNDING TO REDUCE DISTRICT
DISTRICT COST PACIFIC LEE AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. RIGHT NOW
DISTRICT PENSION RATES ARE
SCHEDULED TO INCREASE NEXT YEAR
ANDTHEN DROP SLIGHTLY THE YEAR
AFTER THAT. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD USE AROUND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION TO SOME WITHOUT THOSE
PENSION RATE INCREASES AT OUT.
ELIMINATE THAT HUMP AND LLOW-
PENSION COSTS TO GROW MORE
SLOWLY AND STEADILY OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. THAT'S REALLY
ARE TAKEN THE PROPOSITION AND
GET BUDGET AND IN A NUTSHELL
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR REACTION
TO THE EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSALS. US AIR CORTEZ WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE AALYST'S
OFFICE- PAGE NINE HAS A LIST
THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSALS AND SINCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALREADY
DESCRIBED FEES- WE'LL JUST MOVE
ALONG TO PAGE TEN. WHICH LISTS
ARE ASSESSMENT INTO
RECOMMENDATIONS A BRIEF SUMMARY
OF OUR SUSSMAN RECOMMENDATIONS-
WITH REGARD TO THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ON THE
GOVERNOR PER PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE TEN THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS AND WE
THINK THE PROGRAMS UNLIKELY TO
ACCOMMODATE. THIS IT TO THE
SICK- ALL OF EXPANSION I'M IN
THIS IS PRIMARILY BECAUSE MORE
OF THAT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
SLOTS AVAILABLE MADE AVAILABLE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WILL
GO AND USE AND WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ALLOCATE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. I'M SO WE THINK
IT'S ARE RECOMMENDING A MORE
MODEST EXPANSION OF A THOUSAND
SLOTS. WITH REGARD TO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL IT'S
UNCLEAR IF THIS NEW DEPARTMENT
ADDRESSES THE STATED PROBLEMS-
AND WERE. IN PRIMARILY BECAUSE
THE PROPOSAL LACKS DETAIL AND
WE'RE AMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
PROJECT THE PROPOSAL. AND WITH
OUR TO THE OFFICE GRANT
PROPOSAL. THIS MIGHT. A KEY
BARRIER FOR JOBS AND SHOULD FOR
SOME PROVIDERS WERE RECKONED
HERE JUST KEEPING A DIFFERENT
FUNDS TO FIGHT. GRAHAM.
QUESTION PERMANENT HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON WELL AS OF GOV
AFFAIRS THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION WILK GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE JUST HEARD FROM OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT MY REMARKS
GENERALLY BE BE SHORT- BUT AS
YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND-
WERE OVER- WERE OVERALL
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES THIS FUNDING
PRESENTS- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PLACES AN EMPHASIS ON ENSURING
AN EQUITABLE EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS A GOAL THAT CD
SUPPORTS AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST OUTLINED- THERE
ARE SEVERAL PROPOSALS THAT
ALIGN WITH THE CD AND THE
STATE'S FOR INTENDED. ARE SOME
OF THE WORK WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ALREADY
UNDERTAKEN. NOW WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ON THOSE PROPOSALS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE BUDGET
SEASON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
QUESTIONS YEAH UP MISTER
VARSITY. THANK YOU ALL AND LIKE
TO START OFF AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE YOU KNOW I. CHECKED
IN WITH MY- SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT AND- THEY THEY
THEY ARE TELLING ME THAT. THE
COLA. A PROPOSED COLA BUT IT'S
A TWO POINT TWO NINE. OR IS IT
YES- IS GROSSLY INADEQUATE TO.
MEET EVEN JUST THEIR JOB
PROJECTED INFLATION ADJUSTED
COSTS TO BEACHES MEET EXISTING
COSTS. HAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- CONSULTED WITH. THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO SEE IF-
YOU KNOW WHAT RESPONSES THEY
THEY THEY'VE GIVEN YOU IN TERMS
OF THE ADEQUACY OF THE PROPOSED
CALL. WE WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON THE
CONCERNED WITH THE LOCAL- GIVEN
THAT I THINK ARE PROJECTION OF
THE COLOR WAS SLIGHTLY HIGHER-
AT LAST YEAR I'M SO THE CALL IS
SET IN STATUTE. ON THE ABILITY
TO PROVIDE MORE COLOR COURSES.
IT CAN BE DONE IF IT'S A
PRIORITY I THINK OUR PROBLEM
WITH THE WAY THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEES STRUCTURES WE HAVE A
LOT OF. LEARN THE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND WHERE WE- LAND
SO AT THE MAY AT. MAY REVISION
OR CERTAINLY WILL LOOK AT THESE
ALL AGAIN BUT- AND GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE HAD. INDICATORS THAT
MAY WOULD PROP MAY LEAD TO A
LESS A TIGHTENING IN THE
GUARANTEE. ALL RIGHT AND- IS- I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- RESPOND TO THE
SAME QUESTIONS I ADDRESS TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT THAT IS THAT. IN
THIS TIME WHEN- MEASURE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE- TALKING ABOUT
NOT BEING ABLE TO- MADE THEIR
EXISTING COSTS LIKE LAUSD
OAKLAND IN SACRAMENTO- AMONG
MANY OTHERS- IN THESE GOOD
BUDGET TIMES ARE WHY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS RATHER THAN FOCUSING
ON HELPING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH THEIR EXISTING COSTS SO
THERE IS NOT ANY CREATION OF A
NEW PROGRAMS WITH THE ON GOING
FUNDS ALL OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU SEE ARE ONE TIME PROGRAMS
WITH ONE TIME FUN AND THEY'RE
TARGETED. INTENSIVE
INTERVENTION AND WHAT WE ALSO
HEAR FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE
WENT OUT ON IN OUR SPECIAL
EDUCATION REFORM EFFORTS THIS
YEAR AND WE SPOKE TO A LOT OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THEIR
NUMBER ONE CONCERNON IS REALLY
TEACHER RETENTION- MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES- BUT ALSO. YOU
KNOW JUST GO TO CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP UNBEATABLE TO
EDUCATE THE STUDENTS IN THEIR
CLASSROOM SO WE WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF THOSE. ISSUES
IN THIS PART MORE TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS AND WE USE THE
ONE TIME FUNNY BECAUSE AGAIN-
AS THE LA POINTED OUT THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT. IF THE GUARANTEE
DROPS REVENUES DROP THOSE CAN
BE REDUCED- AND THE NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET. IS THAT THE ENTIRE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
DESIGNED TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. I THINK WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS THAT IN SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH DEEP YES
IT SHOULD- BUT WERE FINING AS
AT THAT OVER THE EIGHT YEARS OF
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING PLAN
THAT WE STILL HAVE POCKETS OF
DEEP POVERTY AND IN THOSE DEEP
ALREADY WERE SEEN DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. I'M SHOWING THIS
PERSISTENT- ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THIS THEY-
COMMUNITY SCHOOL OPPORTUNITY
GRANT IS REALLY RECOGNIZING
THAT A CHILD EDUCATION IS NOT
ONLY IN THE CLASSROOM BUT IT'S
ALL OF THE OTHER SUPPORT AND
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO ACCESS EDUCATION WHEN
THEY ARE IN THE CLASSROOM. SO
THESE PROP THESE PROPOSALS ARE
NOT RIGHT NOW OR THAT TYPE OF
RAP SERVICES NOT READILY
AVAILABLE IN THE CLASSROOM SO
SOMEBODY'S TARGET INTERVENTIONS
ARE TRY REALLY RECOGNIZING THAT
WE NEED TO GET INTO THE
CLASSROOM IT AIDS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
TO GET SERVICES TO STUDENTS AND
HOW. WELL HOPEFULLY. BE
DECREASED ACHIEVEMENT. WE'VE
HAD EIGHT YEARS OF LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. TO
ATTEMPT TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. HOW WOULD YOU
CHARACTERIZE THE PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE. IN TRUMP I WOULD SAY THE
SO WE'VE MADE GREAT WE HAVE
MADE PROGRESS IN MANY AREAS AND
WE ARE SEEN ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
GROWS BUT WE JUST HAVE SOME
PERSISTENT ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
THOSE ARE WAS STUDENTS THAT
HAVE- A LOT OF. DO THEY NEED
THEY NEED MORE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. WE NEED TO GIVE THEM
MORE MONEY. I DON'T KNOW THE
GIVING MORE MONEY IS THE ISSUE
I THINK A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MEDIATE ADDITIONAL
STATE SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
WITH. THAT IS MORE TARGETED.
THAT THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AT THIS POINT. CITY IN
SUPPORT IS MORE MNEY. TARGETED
TARGETED OKAY- WHAT WHAT IS
YOUR- RESPONSE TO THE LA OWES-
RECOMMENDATION THAT TO. THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT MOST OF THE-
ONE TIME- INITIATIVES OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S ONE TIME
INITIATIVES TO FREE UP MORE
THAN A BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
DISTRICTS WITH ONE TIME A
RELIEF TO PAY DOWN PENSION
LIABILITIES. WE WERE VERY
DISAPPOINTED EIGHT WHAT WAS SO
LAST YEAR WE DID INVEST THREE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DOING JUST THAT YES EXACTLY OUR
CONCERN IS THAT WE INVESTED NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND THE LA OWES
PROPOSAL IS TO PRO TO INVEST
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. SO WE JUST KNOW
THAT THAT'S A CONCERN. OUR
THANK YOU. SOMEONE NUMBER
LIMóN THANK YOU AT AND I WANT
TO ECHO WHAT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ECHOED ABOUT
THE COLA- IT'S A BIG DEAL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO WEST SO IF IT'S
NOT IN PROJECTED BUDGET I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
PRIORITIZE IT EATS IT'S AN
IMPORTANT. AT ELEMENT THAT WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ACHIEVE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
AND I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE
MORE BASIC ELEMENTS AS I.
REVIEW AND LOOK OVER- ALL OTHER
IDEAS- YOU KNOW I LIKE A LOT OF
THESE ONE TIME SPENDING.
CATEGORIES BUT I ALSO FIND
THAT- THE START OFF AS ONE TIME
BUT THEN WE'RE BACK AVING THIS
CONVERSATION WILL WE FIND IT
LAST YEAR- AND SO I DO WE KEEP
GOING. ON AND KEEP FINDING IT
SO- IN THIS DOES SEEM LIKE A
LONG LIST OF ONE TIME-
INITIATIVES- AND I EIGHT THINK
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO PRIORITIZE
WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. ON SOME OF THESE-
ALL ARE GOOD ALL I LIKE ALL I
CAN LIVE WITH- HOWEVER I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE CAN DO ALL OF
THEM. I'M ON THE CHILD
NUTRITION RE AT REIMBURSEMENT.
IN NUMBER MORE BROADLY ON
NUTRITION- TOGETHER I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER WHO'S
NOT HERE AND I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
ALSO. I ENSURE THAT ON THE
CHILD NUTRITION FRIENDS- WE ARE
DOING MORE TO AT. ADVANCE AND
TO THAT. IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
SOME OF THIS IS CALIFORNIA
GROUND- AND ANYTHING THAT
THAT'S ANOTHER IMPORTANT PIECE-
BECAUSE WE GROW A LOT OF OUR
OWN AG HERE- AND- WHILE IT'S
NICE TO SAY THAT IT COULD BE A
CALIFORNIA GROWN A THINK THAT
IT WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO MEET.
OTHER NEEDS THAT WE HAVE- TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS I IN
OUR SCHOOLS ARE. RECEIVING THE
BEST- FROM OUR STATE SO I JUST
WANTED TO THROW THAT OUT THERE
I THINK IT'S WERE THERE. A
CONSIDERING. OKAY SIR DONALD.
THANK YOU ALL JUST KIND OF DOUG
GO THROUGH A FEW THINGS HERE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND- JUST GET A
DRAWING ON THE RESERVE THE PER-
IT IS KIND OF A CONCERN TO ME
AND THE TIME LIKE THIS- AGAIN
THE COLA HER MAKES PRESS. PURSE
STRIPPERS I KNOW THAT AND ALL
WE WANT TO SEE OF THE LARGER
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENT TO THE
ASSEMBLY THERE WAS WHAT IT TO
YOUR COME. OF EIGHT THREE POINT
THREE BILLION TOTAL FUNK.
READING MY MOTHER PAYMENT THIS
YEAR YES BUT I'VE WE RENAME AND
IF I'M NOT AT THIS YEAR PAYMENT
UP I THINK I'D BE GREAT BECAUSE
AGAIN THAT. THAT THAT THAT
PUSHES DOWN THOSE OUT YOUR
COSTS- AND AGAIN THAT'S-
PROBABLY MORE GENERAL FUND
DISCUSSION THE NINETY EIGHT
BUT- STILL- PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT- THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY FOR. ONE YEAR FOR ONE
EFFORT. I WAS A RADIO. UNDER
THAT UMBRELLA BUT JUST THAT
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY. AND
HAVING BEEN IN A SCHOOL FOR
MANY YEARS I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WHEN A LOT OF MONEY COME. I
DON'T KNOW IF IT ALWAYS AND-
THE WHITES FACTIONS ARE.
CAUTIOUS PUTTING PUSHING OUT
TOO MUCH- TOO FAST YOUR MAY
EXPRESS. ABOUT THE C. C. E. THE
CALIFORNIA CLAPPER WHICH I
THINK IS A GOOD IDEA I DID THIS
AND I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CREATED THE WHICH IS A
GOOD THING. I JUST LIKE TO SEE
MORE WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND-
WHO OVERSEES I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED ON THAT ON THAT MODEL
THERE- AND THEN ON THE
SPECIALIST PROPOSAL I MEAN
THERE THERE'S A GOOD START
THERE WE HAVE SOME GOOD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT SOME OF
OUR DISTRICTS THAT HAVE MORE
MA- MODERATE TO SEVERE
STUDENTS. SHOULD THERE BE A
WAITED FOR ME OF SOME FASHION.
ALONG WITH EQUALIZATION EFFORTS
AS WELL- THERE SOME STUDIES IN
THERE I THINK WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT. STUDIES AND I WAS TALK
ABOUT HOLDING UP MONEY FOR NEXT
YEAR. TO IMPLEMENT. THE DID YOU
DON'T TALK ABOUT SIMPLEMENT
SOME OF THE INFORMATION
GARNERED FROM ONE OF THE
STUDIES THAT MAKING SENSE. SO
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED. YEAH YEAH
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR PRESCHOOL EARLY
INTERVENTION AND GRANTS AND
THAT MONEY- IS ONE TIME A GOING
OUT A ONE TIME COVER THE INTENT
IS THAT IT WILL BE ON GOING IN
AND INCLUDED IN THE NEXT PHASE
OF THE FORMULA ON BUT THERE ARE
SOME STUDIES GOING ON RIGHT
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
BUDGET. SPCIAL EDUCATION
RELATED TO KINDA HELP INFORM
WHERE WE MOVE ON ARE WORTH FAR
MORE PAYING FOR THESE STUDIES
ARE NOT HAVING SOME ONE CALL
FOUNDATIONS GARNER ALL THIS
MONEY I GET KINDA CONCERNED
WEAVING WE WANTED ID WE SHOULD
PAY THAT SAY I WANT SOMEBODY
ELSE MY- ULTIMATE CONTROL WHAT
THAT STAY LOOKS LIKE HAVING
THIS VENTURE AS WELL. COULD TO
A WORKER AND THIS IN ONE STUDY
IS A STUDY CURRENTLY GOING ON-
THE PRIVATE COMMISSION WITH
PRIVATE FUNDS BY WEST ADD THAT
IS LOOKING AT STATE EDUCATION
FUNDING AND WHAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IN OUR STATE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN DONE
IN MANY YEARS THE SUSPECT OF
WHO'S INVOLVED BECAUSE I REALLY
THINK. THERE SHOULD BE PUBLIC
HANSON ENOUGH FOR LIKE AND I
WORRY ABOUT SENDING THESE
STUDIES OFF YES PROFESSOR OUT
THERE AND GET WHAT THEY WANT
BUT ULTIMATELY SHOULD BE WHAT
CAL KIDS. THAT THOSE WILL BE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD-
WELL. OKAY THAT I THINK MISTER
MURATSUCHI DID ALLUDE ON THE
OPPORTUNITY GRANTS IS NOT WHAT.
OUR CONSERVE OUR OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
GRANTS ARE FOR- THAT'LL BUT
AGAIN ONLY A POINT OF A
CONVERSATION AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU CAN I GO BACK
TO THE LA ON YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. SO. IT'S THE
ONE BILLION PUT IT IS THAT
ONGOING OR FOR ONE TIME MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT CARBON
FINES PROPOSALS ONE TIME
PROPOSALS BUT WITH ON GOING POP
NINETY EIGHT MONEY SO OKAY AS
YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER NIXING THOSE AND USE
THOSE FOR THINGS LIKE. PENSION
FINANCES ARE YOU PROPOSING
THAT. JUST A ONE TIMER LOOKING
ONLINE. SIX SO THE ONE THE ONE
BILLION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THAT IS RELATED
TO ONE TIME FUNDS AND SOME OF
THAT IS RELATED TO ON GOING
FUNDS IT'S PULLING FROM
DIFFERENT THE PROPOSAL'S ESCORT
TO DIFFERENT YEARS SOME SCORES
TO THE BUDGET YEARS SOME TO
PREVIOUS YEARS. I THINK WE
ENVISION THE PENSION PAY DOWN
BEING A ONE TIME PROPOSAL- JUST
GIVEN THAT IT'S RESPONDING
SPECIFICALLY TO SOME OF THE
COST PRESSURES DISTRICTS ARE
FACING. KIND OF RIGHT NOW AND
IN THIS COMING YEAR WHO. OKAY.
PARTIALLY ADDRESSES THAT OKAY
WELL THANK YOU THIS THIS OF
COURSE IS OUR OVERVIEW WILL DIG
INTO THESE ISSUES- MUCHMORE IN
THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS
AND- WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY WE'LL GET TO
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT SO HE PLEASE
LINE AT- IN THE MIDDLE AND
PLEASE KEEP YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT
TO SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS SIXTY
SECONDS OR LESS.
YEAH. GETTING
THEM ALL THE STATE'S FIRST
MISTER OSAMA. OKAY PLEASE BEGIN
HI ON A HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS OF AN ELLA FOR ANYA- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR MCCARTY HOW YOU
OPEN THIS IN SAYING THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF INTRIGUING
PROPOSALS IN THIS BUDGET- THAT
WE ALL HAVE TO CONSIDER BEFORE
US IN THE FUTURE THIS YOU'RE
MOVING FORWARD WE COULDN'T
AGREE MORE- AND- WE ALSO YOU
KNOW ECHO THE CLEAR- LENDS OF
EQUITY ON THE ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT TWO BILLION IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND REALLY
DETERMINING HOW WE USE THOSE
FUNDS IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MANNER- BUT UNITED WAY AND OUR
PARTNERS. LOOK FOR PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- TIED FOR
DEEP CONNECTIONS AND
COMMUNITIES ON WHAT WORKS BEST
FOR SIX MILLION PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS- ESPECIALLY THOSE
EXPERIENCING POVERTY IN TRAUMA-
RESEARCH BACKS WHAT WE ALL
INTUITIVELY KNOW WRAPPING KIDS
IN NEEDED SUPPORTS AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE- PUT THEM ON THE BEST
YOUR DIRECTORY IN LIFE- AND WE
WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT IN THIS
CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AN OPPORTUNITY GRANTS-
THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT CBO'S
PLATE IN WRAPPING STUDENTS- AND
FAMILIES IN THOSE SERVICES AND
NOT HAVING TO NECESSARILY
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR
DIRECT SERVICES BUT TAPPING
INTO THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTS
THAT ALREADY EXIST IN THE
WILLINGNESS OF PARTNER IN THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR. TO
COME IN RAP THOSE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES PORTS I WE DO BELIEVE
THAT INVESTMENTS LIKE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND HEALTHY START- ARE
REALLY THE WAY TO GET TO A
TARGETED AN INTENTIONAL-
INTERVENTION- AND WE ARE EAGER
TO CONTINUE THE- CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING STERILE
ALYSSA TEACH PLUS- AND WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPERINTENDENT'S
OUR CONVERSATION ABOUT BOTH-
ADDRESSING OUR UNDERLYING
FISCAL CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
REALLY LOOKING AT. SOME OF THE
DUST UP Q. LEVERS FOR
ADDRESSING OPPORTUNITY MAY
GAPS. AND WE AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR THAT MAKING SURE WE
HAVE A WELL PREPARED WELL
SUPPORTED DIVERSE TEACHER WHAT
TEACHER WORK FORCES ONE OF THE
GREATEST DRIVERS. OF ADDRESSING
THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND SO
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE A LOT OF
THE INVESTMENTS. THEY ALSO WERE
EXCITED TO HEAR HIM TALK ABOUT
INVESTING IN WHAT WORKS I THINK
WE HAVE CHALLENGES AND KNOW
WHAT WORKS. ON AND SO WE WOULD
SUPPORT AT WITH ALONG WITH SOME
OF THESE INVESTMENTS WE REALLY
BUILD UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM THESE
FROM WHAT WE'RE DOING SO-
HAVING MORE MEANINGFUL
EVALUATION. BUILDING THE
CAPACITY OF THE CTC TO SUPPORT
SOME OF THESE GRANT PROGRAMS-
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE HAVING
THE SUSTAINABLE AND IMPACT THAT
WE HAVE HOPE FOR. AND IF WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT DIVERSIFYING OUR
TEACHING FORCE LET'S BE
EXPLICIT. LET'S MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THAT IS A GOAL AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE MEASURING-
AND THEN WE JUST ALSO WANT TO
REINFORCE THE FOCUS ON MAKING
SURE THAT ALL CFF IS WORKING
THAT IS ADDRESSING THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND SHE MAIN CAPS-
THAT THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MURATSUCHI TALK TO AND SO PART
OF THAT IS MAKING SURE THIS
GREAT TRANSPLANT IN CANADA.
THANK YOU. SO GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CONGRADULATIONS ERIN NICE TO
SEE ON THE SIDE. PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
FIRST OF ALL JUST WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE PRIORITIES
THEY'VE SET OUT- TO ADJUST THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. WE APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S SUPPORT
ADDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AS
WELL AS LCF. LAKE HAS
TRADITIONALLY SUPPORTED-
EFFORTS TO INCREASE. THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA THAT
TARGETS AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT. BUT WE THINK AT THE
SAME TIME WE CAN FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS ON IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
LIKE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. MICHAEL
HAS A PILOT RIGHT NOWWE HAVE
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH BOTH THE COUNTY.
AS WELL AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
OTHERS. TO A DROP. TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS WHO. WE
REALLY NEED TO ADDRESS THE
WHOLE CHILD. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON FOR MANY
YEARS WE KNOW IT'S BEEN A
PRIORITY OF THIS COMMITTEE. THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SO WE REALLY DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH-
ENTITIES. AND WE THINK TO
SOMETHING WE CAN DO. WELL IT
INCREASE. AT TEN FUNDING THANKS
VERY MUCH. SUBJECT CLOSE MY A
COMPLIMENT I APPRECIATE THAT
WERE WERE LOOKING TO. SOME
NINETY DOLLARS TO THE THAT'S
PROPER NEED FOR THE PURPOSE
THERE'S OTHER THINGS NEED TO
HAPPEN TO LIKE ELLIE A BILLING.
ALL THOSE COMETA CALYX ADDRESS
THERE'S SOME OTHER. DYNAMICS
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS- AS A
LEGISLATURE AS WELL. THANK YOU.
DINEEN MICHELETTI CULVER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS- THAT WERE MADE TODAY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S. OF JANUARY
PROPOSED BUDGET WE WOULD AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT YOU HAVE
TO SHORE UP EXISTING PROGRAMS-
IN DOING NOT. ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
RECEIVE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE SLOTS LET ME PUT IN
CONTEXT. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS OF ONLY RECEIVE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND SLOTS. ROUGHLY
TOTAL TODAY WE SIR FEWER THAN
SIXTY THOUSAND IN THE WORKING
POOR PROGRAM YET THE NUMBER OF
INCOME ELIGIBLE HAS SURGED OVER
TWO MILLION. THAT PROGRAM
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT IN REGARDS
TO THE COLA IT'S HOLY- IT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH. SO IN OUR
PROGRAMS ARE WAS PROPOSED A TWO
POINT 29% COLA. BUT IN THE SAME
TOKEN. THERE WAS AN ADJUSTMENT
OF CAP PRO- FOR CAP PROGRAMS
ELIMINATING TWO POINT OH ONE
PERCENT. SO WE'RE NOT EVEN
GETTING THE BASIC TWO POINT 29%
COLA. IN REGARDS TO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
POINT FOR CONVERSATION. BUT YOU
HAVE TO PUT THE OTHER PROGRAMS
SUCH AS HOT AS A TEAM TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE ARE PROGRAMS THAT
ALSO TOUCH HOMELESSNESS. IN THE
SAME CONVERSATIONS IN THE SAME
DEPARTMENT IF YOU FINALLY RATES
HAVE TO BE AT THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OR CURRENT LEVELS NOT
AT TWENTY SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI GOOD EVENING-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
CONVERSATION AS WELL NEED A B.
C. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA JUST A COUPLE
OF POINTS- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT TEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STATE PRESCHOOL-
SLOTS AS PART OF THE THREE OR
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THEIR SPACES SO VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. HOWEVER WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THE INCREASE OF SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE INFANT
AND TODDLER SLOTS IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH FOR THE NEED AND
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT NUMBER INCREASE AS WE
START TALKING- A- FEW- FURTHER
PROPOSALS- IT WOULD AGREE SOME
OF THE OTHER SIDE. SENTIMENTS
NOT SOMETHING I WOULD NORMALLY
TALK ABOUT BUT CERTAINLY THE
COLA IS NOT SUFFICIENT ALSO FOR
OUR EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WE DO KNOW WE
DEFINITELY HAVE A REIMBURSEMENT
I'M RIGHT CRISIS- IN THIS
STATE. IN REGARDS TO THE-
PROPOSAL THE NEW DEPARTMENT ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT MY
ORGANIZATION HAS NOT YET TAKEN
A POSITION ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. HOWEVER WE ARE VERY
ENCOURAGE AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE A WE DO
THINK THAT THERE ARE
POSSIBILITIES HERE BUT AS YOU
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
WHAT IS MOST BENEFICIAL FOR
CHILDREN AND COMMUNITIES AND
ENSURING WE ARE- MEETING THE
NEEDS. OF THOSE ARE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN OUT IN THE
STATE AND NECESSARILY
ADMINISTRATIVE NEEDS ARE
PROFESSIONAL SO I THINK YOU.
FAIR ABOUT JUST AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS VERY
APPRECIATIVE THE CONVERSATION
THAT TOOK PLACE THAT IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
PROPERLY SERVE. WE MUST BE ABLE
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN. THE
NECESSARY STUFF WHICH REALLY IS
ADDRESSING AND COMPENSATION.
AND WHAT COMES WITH THAT WHICH
IS INCREASING COST TO PENSION
SO WE WILL REALLY DO.
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION THAT
WITHIN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM-
UNFORTUNATELY ARE ALL CFF TIED
TO A TWO POINT TWO NINE. A COLA
WHICH WE HAD BEEN ANTICIPATING
IT TO BE 3% IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET DOES LEAD TO.
CONVERSATIONS I VALLEY A LEVEL
OF REDUCTIONS AND SO WE- HOPE
TO WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
ACCESS TO ANY AVAILABLE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI A GOOD EVENING IT'S GOT MORE
I'M WITH COULD ANGLO- WE SERVE
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME
CHILDREN- WITH PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE IN THE BAY AREA. AND
I JUST WANTED TO VOICE OUR
STRONG. SUPPORT FOR THE CREE OF
A NEW. EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE HOLISTIC THAT SERVE
THE WHOLE CHILD. IT'S NOT THAT
IT'S NOT EDUCATION IT'S THAT
IT'S MORE THAN JUST EDUCATION-
WHEN WE CAN BRING TOGETHER
FUNDING STREAMS. THAT MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO GET NOT
JUST THE CHILD CARE THEY NEED.
BUT ALSO THE MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH THE HEALTH CARE
THAT THEY NEED. OUR OUT WITHOUT
HAVING TO ENROLL IN FIVE SIX
SEVEN DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PROGRAMS. THAT'S THE KIND OF
CHANGE THAT- WE SUPPORT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THANK YOU. HARD TO
FOLLOW SCOTT. GOOD ABOUT GOOD
AFTERNOON PUTTING HER ON BEHALF
OF EARLY EDUCATOR FOR NOW I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE SUPPORT
THAT- SCOTT FOR ME KIDDING GO-
OFFERED- WITH RESPECT TO THE
DIP CREATION OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT WE HEAR THE
CONCERNS FROM THE FIELD- ABOUT
AND MAKING SURE THAT SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS TO FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN ARE NOT DISRUPTED AND
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
THAT WE'RE ALSO COMMITTED TO
THE IDEA THAT- THE NEW
DEPARTMENT SHOULD HOUSE MORE
THAN CHILD CARE THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY LOOK AT THE AT. THE
TOTALITY OF SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT- HEALTHY CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THAT AS WELL WE
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR IS TO WE
THINK THAT THIS IS A- THE RIGHT
VISION FOR CALIFORNIA AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WE SUPPORT IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BEVERLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF YOU TO THE ASK ME
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY- WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
MINISTRATIONS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING EASY
PROGRAMS. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE CAN BE
BENEFITS ASKS THE- SB I POINTED
OUT TODAY. A WITH STREAMLINING
A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS UNDER
ONE COMPREHENSIVE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE.
WILL BE A LOT OF WORK IN
COORDINATION NEEDED FOR THIS
ENDEAVOR AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS AROUND
THIS TOPIC. AND WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE CHAIR. COMMENT AROUND
MAKING SURE THAT WE FOCUS ON
THE LINES OF THE FAMILY CHILD
AND PROVIDERS THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. PHILOSOPHICALLY WE
SUPPORT MANY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS ARE A LOT OF GOOD
IDEAS AND THIS BUDGET BUT IT IS
A BALANCING ACT. OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IS INCREASING THE BASE
GRANT- FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS- IN
ORDER TO DO THAT AS MANY OF THE
MEMBERS MENTIONED- WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
REVENUE. AND TALK ABOUT HOW WE
INCREASE REVENUE SIGNIFICANTLY
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT INCREASING
THE COAL- WE THINK THAT'S TOO
LOW I THINK BEYOND THAT WE NEED
TO INVEST IN WHAT WORKS WHAT WE
KNOW WORKS WE'RE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE TEACHER RECRUITMENT RICK
RETENTION PROPOSALS. WE DO KNOW
THAT THE CLASSIFIED SCHOOLING
EMPLOYEE TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM WORKS WE HAVE DATA ON
THAT WE SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF THAT- WE ALSO KNOW THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WORK- WORK-
IF HE'S BEEN A LEADER IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS NATIONALLY
AND SEE UP HE'S BEEN A LEADER
IN. IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO WE WOULD SUPPORT THAT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
MONEY CRENNEL'S ON BEHALF OF
THE EASY COALITION. WOULD LIKE
TO SAY WE APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE GOVERNOR
DID PROVIDE HIS BUDGET FOR
PRESCHOOL SPACES- INCLUDING. A
LIMITED NUMBER OF A P. SPACES
WITH THE PROP SIXTY FOUR
DOLLARS- BUT WE THINK IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE INVEST MORE
WE HAVE OVER TWO MILLION
CHILDREN AND WHO HAVE NEED IN
THE STATE KNOWLEDGE ABILITY. WE
BELIEVE WE NEED TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMATIC- INCREASES IN THE
SYSTEM. ADDITIONALLY WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S A
ABILITY TO- WILLINGNESS TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE NEW
DEPARTMENT AND LOOK FOR TO
SPEAKING AND WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THE
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR- MEMBERS- INDICATOR ACHO
NOW WITH SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- INTO YOUR
COMMENTS MISTER MERRETT TO EACH
THROUGH T. POLLOCK EYES. WE
WOULD AGREE THAT EL CFF IS THE
POLICY A VERY IMPORTANT POLICY
TO CLOSE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS. I AND WE WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO TALK WITH YOU IN
THE COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE WORKING. TOWARDS THAT
GOAL- WE SHARE A LOT OF THE
GOALS THAT ARE ARTICULATED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
OB BUT WE DO HAVE DEEP CONCERNS
I IN AN URGENCY IN THE WAY THAT
THE PROPOSAL'S OUR STRUCTURE.
WE FEEL THAT IT REALLY LIMITS
OUR CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO.
FINANCIALLY PLAN AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS. WE DO HAVE FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS. I IN TERMS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
SOME CHANGES WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. THE FIRST ONE BEING THAT
WE WILL LOOK TO SEE ALLOCATION
ON SPECIAL ED- BASED ON WATER
IN SEVERE THIS. OF STUDENTS
LIKE THAT THE LA HAS PROVIDER
REPORT. ON WHAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON IN SPECIAL ED SO THAT WE
THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. TERMS OF ALL OF
THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD BE BEST
TO PROVIDE THOSE. ANA ABA BASIS
STATE WIDE. AND FINALLY TO LAST
ISSUES IN TERMS OF THE COLA SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED IT'S ESTIMATING A
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION. DOLLAR
REDUCTION IN. A WITH THE TWO
POINT 29% COLON THINK WE
BELIEVE GOING BACK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT. AND ONE TIME PENSION
PAYMENTS AS WELL THANK IN THE-
GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION. I'LL JUST
KIND OF SAD I ALIGNED MYSELF
WITH A VARIETY OF THE COMMENTS
BEING SAID ESPECIALLY THOSE
MISTER MERRETT CG WITH REGARDS
TO LC FF. WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH A LOT OF THE- COMPETITIVE
GRANT TYPES OF THINGS THE
GOVERNOR DOES HAVE IN HIS
BUDGET. WE GET A LOT OF WINNERS
AND LOSERS THOSE ARE ONLY GOING
TO GO TO A COUPLE DISTRICTS.
EVERYBODY'S GOT THE TYPES OF
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IF YOU'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THE SOMEWHAT
FARING GIVE DISTRICTS A CHANCE
TO PARTICIPATE. THAT DOES NEED
TO BE KIND OF DOWN ON A MUCH
MORE GLOBAL BASIS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. SOMETHING ADDRESS TO THE
PENSIONS HOWEVER NOT OUT OF
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS- BECAUSE
THAT FRANKLY JUST THAN WE DEBT
REDUCES FOR THE PROGRAM
OFFERINGS FOR KIDS. AND WE DO
LOOK FORWARD THOUGH TO THE
DISCUSSIONS COMING UP I WITH
REGARDS TO THE SPECIAL AT
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
RACHEL'S CONSUMERS ARE WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES. WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR KEEPING THE
COMMITMENT OR EQUITY FUNDING
FORMULA LC A FAST. HONORING
PROP NINETY EIGHT THIS WAY IS
NOT A GIVEN WE APPRECIATE IT.
AND AS ALL OF KNOWLEDGE HERE
OUR SYSTEM IS AN ADEQUATELY
FUNDED TO MEET THE TASK OF
SERVING OUR- STUDENTS- LIKE
OTHER PUBLIC SERVANTS. IN
CALIFORNIA THE DEBT WE OWE
SCHOOL STAFF AND RETIREMENT
EMMETT BENEFITS SHOULD NOT BE
PAID OUT OF THE SCARCE FUNDING
WE COVER FOR EDUCATION BUT FROM
THE GENERAL FUND THE STATE CAN.
COLLECT SMALL CALIFORNIANS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO FLUSH OUT THE
PROPOSAL'S ON I'LL SEE IF OF
TRANSPARENCY. WE AGRE WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR. BUT SIMPLY
TRACKING MONEY DOES NOT MAKE A
CATEGORICAL. FINALLY SINCE I'LL
SEE OF UP IS BECAUSE IT HAS
BECOME PAINFULLY CLEAR THAT WE
HAVE BEEN SUFFICIENTLY FOCUSED
ON PREPARING IN DEVELOPING OUR
TEACHERS. WE IDENTIFY TEACHERS
THE STATE PRIORITY NUMBER ONE
BUT DIDN'T FIND IT. WE THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL FOR
TO IMPROVE OUR TEACHER WORK
FIRST OUR ROOT CAUSES. TO
ADDRESSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
WE HAVE THE GREATEST CONCERN
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS. THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
BEAR THE BRUNT OF AN ADEQUATELY
FUNDED TEACHERS AND GETTING
HIGH QUALITY TEACHERS TO THEIR
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE THE FOCUS OF
OUR STATE'S EFFORTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS JUST AROUND OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP. OVERALL
WE SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT OF
THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE IN HIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT SUPPORT
FAMILY AND CHILDREN- IN
PARTICULAR WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
OF THE STATE'S FIRST DEPARTMENT
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
WE THINK IT'S ABOLD MOVE TO
CENTER CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
GOVERNMENT AND DECISION MAKING.
AS YOU KNOW CHILDREN UNDER
FIVE- IS THE WHEN THEIR THEIR
MOST CRITICAL FOR. AN
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
MOTIONAL AND SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT
AS WELL. THIS NEW DEPARTMENT
EXEMPLIFIES A COMMITMENT TO
LINE STRATEGIES PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TOWARD INTEGRATED
WHOLE CHILD APPROACH. WHOLE
FAMILY MISSION THAT WILL ENABLE
US TO SERVE YOUNG CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES FOR MORE
EFFICIENT GOVERNMENT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU YOU. ABIGAIL ROMERO'S WITH
THE LEADING A COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT.
AND 52% OF THE KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA- LIKE THE YOU KNOW
SEND THESE INVESTMENTS. AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD ARE CRITICAL TO
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'VE CALIFORNIA
WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR THE CONTINUED
PRIORITIZATION AND INVESTMENT
IN EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION.
AND URGE THEM TO STAY THE
COURSE AND MEETING THE
PRESCHOOL PROMESAS INCREASING
ACCESS FOR CHILD CARE AND
PAYING OUT OF ADEQUATELY FOR
THAT QUALITY OUR CHILDREN
DESERVE. AND SUPPORTING THE
WORK FORCE TO BE THE VERY BEST
FIRST TEACHERS THEY CAN BE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND STAFF
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS- WE DID SUBMIT A
LETTER WITH SOME OF OUR INITIAL
REACTIONS TO THE BUDGET. BUT I
JUST KNOW TODAY- I THINK YOUR
DISCUSSION HAS. I LIKE THE
PHRASE THAT- MISTER RAP USE
THAT A BALANCING ACT. ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THAT WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ON
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
WE THINK THEY WILL MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF MANY STUDENTS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME- MANY OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL TELL YOU IN THE
COUNTY THAT- THAT THAT IS NOT
THEIR HIGHEST PRIORITY. AND
THEY ARE SUFFERING FROM FISCAL
PRESSURES AND THEY WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION ON
THINGS LIKE A- A PENSION
RELIEF- A PROPOSAL OR OTHER
AREAS THAT GIVE THEM A LITTLE
MORE FLEXIBILITY. TO DETERMINE
BASED ON THEIR THEIR OWN
PRIORITIES THE BEST USE OF THE
PHONES DOLLARS. AND WILL
CONTINUE THAT THAT CONVERSATION
AS A SUB COMMITTEE PROCESS
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS J'AI SUPPRESS IT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. FIRST ONE WITH A
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR A GREAT
FRAME WITH THAT HIS ISSUED IN
THIS GENERAL BUDGET. WE WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU TO PROTECT
SOMEBODY IMPORTANT FUNDING
THAT'S ALREADY IN THERE. ARE
THERE'S BEEN PENSION OF CHILD
NUTRITION THAT'S WHEN AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS PUT TOGETHER
SOME TRAINING FUND. AS WELL
SOME INCREASE IN THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION WHO ASK FOR YOUR HELP
TO PROTECT THAT- IN TERMS OF
TRAINING WHICH WOULD JUST ASK
PARITY. DOCTOR TRAINING FUNDS
OF ANY THAT YOU SET ASIDE GO TO
CERTIFICATES AS WELL AS
CLASSIFY STAFF. WERE THE FIRST
THE LAST AND STUDENTS TYPICALLY
WILL SEE AT THE SCHOOL SITE AND
WE HAVE EVERY ISSUE FOR HEALTH
CARE OF TO SCALE WE HAVE NOW.
AND HOW MEMBERS THE DOES
CONSERVE TRAINING TO SAFETY TO
ALL THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT OUR MEMBERS AND
STUDENTS FAMILIES FACE. FINALLY
WE ALSO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR. THE POSTERS PEACE
BUT WE WOULD ASK THAT THERE BE
A PARODY ISSUE FOR THE POST
CLASSIFIED STAFF. INTO SCHOOL
FUN. THANK YOU SO MAKE YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M JAKE BREMNER HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AS WELL AS
OUR PARTNERS AT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE AND- DOZENS
OF OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT ARE PART OF THE COLLEGE
FOR ALL COALITION. AND WE'RE
HERE TO ASK THAT YOU. REINVEST
IN THE COLLEGE READINESS BLOCK
GRANT. AS YOU MAY KNOW IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE STATE
ALLOCATED RESOURCES ON A ONE
TIME BASIS TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
OVER THREE YEARS. IN TARGETING
SUPPORT FOR OUR NEEDIEST
STUDENTS AND HELPING THEM BE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY. FOR COLLEGE
AND BE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING SO
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS TO DO
THINGS LIKE. COVER TEST EXAM
FEES FOR BOTH ADMISSIONS AND A.
P. TESTS HELP MORE STUDENTS
ACCESS TO A TO G. COLLEGE
READINESS CURRICULUM. AND
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
COUNSELING SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES- HOWEVER
AS I KNOW MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ARE WELL AWARE. THERE
ARE STILL PERSISTENT RACIAL
EQUITY GAPS THAT WE MUST
ADDRESS- HIGH SCHOOLS HAVE ONLY
GRADUATED 37% OF OUR LET THE
NEXT MALES. AND 33% OF OUR
BLACKS MALES AS COLLEGE READY-
THIS REALLY CALLS ATTENTION TO
THE NEED TO INVEST IN THESE.
TARGETED SERVICES ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
DOING SO. THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MRS CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS POSH UNDER THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE U. SEASON
ASSOCIATION DOESN'T HAVE. AS A
PART OF THE COLLEGE- FOR ALL
POLLUTION. TO ASK FOR AND
RESPOND REINVESTMENT INTO THE
COLLEGE RENDON'S BLOCK GRANT-
BECAUSE WE SEE THAT AS
ESSENTIAL TO PROMOTING
DIVERSITY IN EQUITY OUR
CAMPUSES. SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN-
WE USING THESE PROGRAM TO YOU
SEE WAS ABLE TO YOU. ARE CREATE
A LOT OF LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
WITH A LOT OF THE SCHOOLS- THAT
ARE UNDER RESOURCES
UNDERFUNDED. ARE TO PROVIDE
MUCH ESSENTIAL OUR RESOURCES
AND SERVICES TO THE STUDENTS ON
THOSE SCHOOLS. ARE THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT BE THERE FOR THEM
TO PREPARE THEM FOR COLLEGE.
AND SO- THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN REALLY REALLY ESSENTIAL
AND CAN PROVIDING THAT SERVICE
BUT THEY WHAT NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PRESS THIS WITHOUT.
ADDITIONAL ONGOING INVESTMENTS
SO- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR THAT REIMBURSEMENT- THIS
YEAR WILL BE THE FIRST YEAR. OF
STUDENTS WHO WERE ASI RBG
SUPPORTED WHO ARE GOING TO BE
WALKING ACROSS THE GRADUATION
STAGE AND WE WANTED TO BE NOT
THE LAST. THANK YOU. CAN REALLY
RESUME REST SOMEPLACE
INTERNATIONAL UNION WE ARE ALSO
A MEMBER OF EDUCATION COALITION
IS ONE TO THROW THAT IN- AND WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
WERE. OVERLOOKED WE WERE JUST
WE NOT TO SEE MODERATE TO
SEVERE A SPECIAL NEEDS INCLUDED
WE BELIEVE THAT NOT ONLY ABOUT
A NEED THAT SCHOOLS ARE. KIND
OF DYING ON THE VINE FIND
FUNDING BUT IT'S ALSO AN EQUITY
ISSUE AS WE HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER
COMPARED TO THE STATE AVERAGE
OF STUDENTS OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME AND THEY'RE SO. IF WE'RE
ABLE TO FUND SEVERE TO MODERATE
WE STOP CANNIBALIZING THE BEES
WHICH STOPS CANNIBALIZING LC FF
SO WE DO THINK THAT OVERALL
IT'S A GOOD INVESTMENT YOUR
DOLLARS- I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
THE POINTS ON THE NUTRITION WE
AGREE WITH THE LOCAL PRODUCE
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT IT'S AN ACCESS ISSUE. WE
HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
ROLLING FOR FEAR- IN FOR YOU
REDUCED PRICE LUNCH- WE'RE
SEEING A DECLINE THERE BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T HAVE
HUNGRY STUDENTS. SO WE THINK
THOSE DOLLARS TO REALLY LOOK AT
ACCESS A SOME SCHOOLS ARE DOING
BREAKFAST LUNCH AND SUPPER
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY SUCCESSFUL
INSURING THAT KIDS GO HOME WITH
A FULL BELLY WHEN WE ENCOURAGE
YOU GUYS TO RECONSIDER- WHERE
THOSE DOLLARS GO. AND WE ALSO
INTO HOW I LIKE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS IS ONE THAT'S NEAR AND
DEAR TO OUR HEART- AND- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE FELT WAS
OVERLOOKED WAS THE INCLUSION OF
COUNTY SERVICES. THEY CAN
ENSURE THAT FAMILY AND FRIENDS
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THE NEED
INCLUDING MEDIC HEALTH AND HOW
FRESH. BUT AS I SAID EVELYN
LETTER WILL REACH OUT WITH YOU
GUYS THINKING YOU VERY MUCH.
CATHERINE GONNA. BEHALF OF
FIRST. LA I WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S GENERATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. CONTINUES TO FOCUS ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT. WE WERE
PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO SEE
THAT TEN THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
PRESCHOOL SPACES. AND INCLUSION
OF ELEAZAR THE PRESCHOOL
FACILITIES EXPANSION PROGRAM.
WE ALSO WANT TO KNOW OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE CONTINUED
PROP SIXTY FOUR ALLOCATION FOR
LIMITED CHILD CARE SPACES. WE
WERE PRETTY. OF LAP YOU'RE
SUPPOSED. TO CHILD CARE SPACES
USING PROP SIXTY FOUR. FUNDS I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT FORMULA
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD. AND
LASTLY WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS FOR THE EASY COALITION
REGARDING THE NEED FOR MORE
CHILD CARE SPACES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR IN THE STATE BUDGET PROCESS
ON THESE ISSUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA- WE'D LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS- ABOUT THE-
MODERATE AND SEVERE- FUNDING
ISSUES WITH. A SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUT WE ARE HEARTENED
ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE- ALSO WE ARE
HEARTENED FOR THE- INVESTMENTS
IN TEACHER PROFESSIONAL.
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS AND ONE
THING IN PARTICULAR THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR TWO IS TO IMPROVE.
THE SAFETY OF STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES- WHEN IT COMES TO
DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES AND-
ALTERNATIVES TO RESTRAIN
SECLUSION WITHIN OUR SCHOOLS.
THESE TACTICS IMPACT NOT ONLY
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY BUT STUDENTS
OF COLORS WHILE WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL ON SPECIAL
ED ISSUES AS THE COMMITTEE WAS
FORD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN THANK
YOU.